would you ever
in this relationship or another
relationship give your partner an
ultimatum
um in terms of
marriage and stuff like that sure it
could be in terms of anything
um
[Music]
i know you see
somehow the world i didn't try to harm
it i tried a little bit why'd you stop
somehow the world will change for me
so wonderful
hi everybody welcome back to a new
episode of the unwax podcast with your
favorite sisters sophia and sistine you
are messing up this whole intro that was
you
that part was you you said your own my
name for your own name i don't know why
because you waited
well
do i automatically have the first sister
name in the the suit like usually we can
go sistine sophia stallone but
apparently
i think you have airplane brain i don't
have an airplane well i did just land
from la and i'm in florida as you guys
can see we're back in our
palm beach studio and you know that we
were doing this for a bit during
quarantine and now it's just become
ritual whenever we're in town yeah i
kind of like it here it's a nice change
of vibe
nice energy we're trying to get our tan
on we love coming to florida we feel
like it really just resets our whole
body the humidity does wonders for our
hair for our skin
sophia you're going to need it you're
looking a little pale a little crusty
right now but me i'm glowing
you're just a horrible person i feel
like every roast every single episode
every roast but yeah i do actually need
a little bit of a tune-up because i
don't think california does too well on
my body i don't think it does well on
anybody it's dry it gets honestly also
the weather has been hot and cold every
other day it's changed it's been a
hundred degrees and it also turns into
60. let's answer the question that i'm
sure the listeners are wondering
cysteine why were you in florida and
sophia why were you still in la
any particular reason
oh yeah i met uh
the boyfriend's family it was just like
dawn well it was it was more of like a
jam-packed weekend he was coming to town
and that was just part of it but it was
really fun it went well i was nervous as
you guys know from last episode but i
didn't do like a show and pony dance
which i normally usually do i was myself
and
it worked thank god i mean there's
nothing more nerve-wracking this is such
a huge step in
a new relationship is meeting your
significant other's family because
on your end you're saying okay i want
everything to go right i want the mom to
like me i want the siblings to like me
the dad i feel like the dad is always
the easiest person we've said that
before they're just the chillest ones
always in every family
but i made sure to tell sophia i was
like you're so
forward and out there and we have a bad
habit of you know sort of throwing it
all on the table trying to say and do
anything to get people to like us
and sometimes that comes off as trying
too hard and we don't want to give the
wrong impression that way so i just said
play it cool you have a bad habit of
when it's silent you feel the need to
fill the silence i didn't that's a good
thing i didn't feel the silence because
you know it's also when you're coming
into a new home you don't want to
they have a routine they have a chat
they normally have with each other and i
want to make sure that i'm not just like
overwhelming the situation because i'm a
new body in there but overall it was
good we went golfing
and he is a really good golf he's not a
golfer but he is a really great golfer
which makes it so much worse
yeah because why wait why
well i said where is like wait yeah
because that means him and i'm assuming
his whole family has been playing for a
really long time so if you go in there
and sophie and i always brag about being
good golfers when well you know we're
okay we don't play that much
we know we're pretty good he's impressed
we talk a bigger game than we really
have and then
now it's time to showcase your skills
and if you flop it is so embarrassing i
i fifty percent flopped
the other fifty percent i killed it but
the problem is like where you're not
consistent with that how bad did you
flop
not bad i honestly had the problem was
and this is a good excuse was i actually
tweaked my back before and so i couldn't
really do a lot of
twisting but i also have another excuses
i haven't played for a couple months all
right she's like back injury i can't i
know and then he was saying the same
thing and he goes and crushes it like
there was probably not one
shank at all it was perfect so what were
you wearing on the golf course this is
the worst part was when he uh told me
that we were gonna go golfing in the
morning i thought
all my golf cl clothes are in florida
because that's all i usually just golf
in florida i don't golf in l.a without
my dad and so i had to piecemeal things
together so i wore my running shoes my
lululemon like kind of weird sweatpants
but not sweatpants and then my one
collared shirt that sounds exactly like
a golf outfit yeah it didn't look that
cute i definitely did not i was not the
cute girl i wasn't the cute golfer girl
that every boy fantasizes
you did what i did i was like the caddy
no you were conservative where i
literally looked like a bar cart girl no
you looked cute i wanted to be my skirt
was so
short
way too short to wear in front of the
parents like that's bad i was wearing a
dodgers hat it was not so weird you guys
know it looked a little funky but it did
the job thankfully and we were out there
for a bit but it was a fun um weekend
and uh we were already a month into our
relationship which has been nice so you
still like the kid yeah i really like
him that's good it's good it's good it's
good what have you been doing here well
no i'm not done talking i don't want to
keep talking about it
so
sophia i'm basically dr phil
so you're one month in
do you feel like
you already know this person are you
excited to explore more about them
what's something
about this individual that you would
love to conquer and get to know in month
two oh my god that's like such an
intense i honestly
like playing with my she's so nervous i
i know it's weird i i you know it's kind
of interesting because
we're open about talking about
relationships when we're single oh yeah
it's really easy but when you're in one
it's almost like i want to gate keep it
and i i'm open to telling you guys about
stuff so then maybe you can learn from
me but
it's i have this instinct where you just
want to not say anything and almost like
still not jinx it and it sounds weird to
say that but i don't know if anyone else
can relate to that when it comes to a
new thing but
what i can say is that what i felt that
this was different from other
relationships that i've been in already
month one was that
i
am
unshamefully myself and he can be too
and it's really warm and it's
comfortable and i think that that was
something i didn't realize i really
needed until i got into this and so i
mean i i don't i just i feel like i i've
been seeing him for a lot longer and i
think that's also another sign that it's
a great thing right you know
did you know that 75 to 90 of all doctor
visits are for stress related issues
many of us are operating on survival
mode expecting our skin bodies and mind
to thrive when we are running on empty
we want to change this reality so we
really love this new purpose-led
california-based hemp cbd startup prima
they are dedicated to helping you rise
above any modern day stress so every day
is a little better with our doctor
formulated clinically validated high
performance products for the skin body
and mind so if you're not sure where to
start
try prima's the daily cbd capsules to
help relieve stress if you're in need of
a restful night's sleep or waking up
groggy in the morning sleep tight will
give you that best sleep you've been
dreaming about lucky for us prima is
offering our listeners an exclusive
limited time twenty percent off offer
with the code unwaxed so head to
dot co with code unwaxed to receive that
limited time 20 off offer to get that
relief you deserve so you can feel
better every day we all want
[Music]
that you actually came up with a really
interesting i don't even know what you
would call it but you
said you came up with this in a dream
and you were just saying that this is
what you should look for in a
relationship and there was no context
tied to it there was no individual
situation that sofia and i have been
through that made her come up with this
but it was really profound it was i
think you should share it yeah i know i
wanted to say it on the last episode but
because we're talking about
relationships why not bring it up and i
came to sistine i mentioned how i was
you know when you have you're either in
your shower you're on a walk or whatever
you're doing you just start to think
about things that's probably you're most
inspired by it's usually when i walk
shower thoughts are so genius
yeah i think i'm mozart in the shower
yeah exactly you start to think about
everything you could have said what you
need to do what you're passionate about
and for me it's on a walk and so
basically on my walk i had this weird
image materialized in front of me where
i pictured me standing just solo by
myself and suddenly it wasn't even a
specific person but they stood behind me
and they were just standing behind me
and then they disappeared and then they
popped up in front of me and their back
was facing me so it's just like almost
like you're standing in a line
and then that person turned around and
looked at me
so it was just kind of like three
different positions the same person just
popping up in different ways and i was
thinking about why that popped up in my
head and cece and i have been talking
for this past month about relationships
and things and like what
what's important and
what
you need to focus on when you're in a
relationship and the questions you need
to ask yourself about how this person is
a part of your life now and how they can
actually manifest in something better or
is it something worse and so i thought
okay maybe this is kind of interesting
and i thought about how when you're in a
relationship and
you're questioning a lot of things and
you don't know whether or not this is
the right one or whether or not this
person is the best person for you
i kind of thought about that image that
was popping up on my walk and i thought
okay maybe i need to ask myself these
three questions
and if i can't
say yes to all three and i can only say
yes to one or two
then i really need to rethink this
person that i'm gonna be spending 99 of
my time with and because when you're in
a relationship it's a lot of energy yeah
so
this is the three questions to get into
it
and it's gonna be quick
when the guy was standing behind me this
version i thought okay if i want a man
to be behind me he would be my
cheerleader he would honor me
he'd be my support system and push us or
push me to like be the best perversion i
can be just be that support that i need
and then when this person's standing in
front of me like he's standing in a line
would he fight for me would he defend me
would he
always root like go after everything
with me and for me and
then when he turned around and looked at
me
did he love me for every single one of
my flaws does he
look at me with adoration no matter how
high of highs or lows of lows you have
and
i think that that's really important
when you're in a relationship and you're
questioning things is does this person
do those three things do they fight for
me
do they
honor me do they protect me
do they support me and do they
completely and
undoubtedly love me for everything that
i am
and if you can't say yes to the front
or you can't say yes with him being in
the back or you can't say yes to him
looking at you at one of those then you
really need to rethink your relationship
and so i thought that i know that sounds
pretty profound and a little bit serious
but
i think a lot of people never know how
to approach
those type of situations
you know that was
deep
yeah
we should put that on a t-shirt yeah
yeah just like well we shouldn't we
should trademark this as your thing so
what are we calling it
it's kind of funny because i i called it
bfa because i thought behind front and
at me but that's all specialists of
performing arts yeah that's the thing
it's a bfa is bachelor performing arts
why do we call it sophia's spell
yeah sophia's three questions about uh
yeah so if you guys are in that
situation and you don't know whether or
not this person is for you and the right
person
and you don't know whether or not you
should move on or stay in it
ask yourself those three questions if
this person can be in front of you
behind you and looking right at you i
love that well let me ask you this
would you ever
in this relationship or another
relationship give your partner an
ultimatum
um in terms of marriage and stuff like
that sure it could be in terms of
anything
um
i think if i got to a certain point in
the relationship where i thought that
there needs to be a next step yeah yeah
no 100 percent they're hard balling
though part about
well i randomly clicked on this new
netflix show and i thought i had to
share it because we we love how much we
watch tv here
and it's called uh the ultimatum
duh
and basically it's these couples that
are dating for one to three years and
either the guy or the girl in the couple
is giving them an ultimatum yeah and
it's sort of like temptation island
which was interesting so they say say if
the guy's like i want the marriage and
the girl says i don't want the marriage
they split up for three weeks have the
opportunity to date the other couples
that they they're the ultimatums yeah
has split up and if they find love with
someone else's have been in a
relationship for a few years then they
can go and be with that person or
say yes to marriage right on the spot
i've been watching it too because it's
been popping up all over my feed
i don't this is crazy by the way like i
thought that i thought that temptation
island was pretty bad
i think this is something a little worse
it's a little worse because one it's
marriage is a contract
and let's be real in the united states
50 of marriages end in divorce so you
got to really be confident with the
person that you're going to marry and if
you've got to be on a tv show to figure
that out
i think you have your answer no but i i
i think is the worst part is that the
couples are in this because they wanted
to get married and the fact that they're
about to see their almost fiance hitting
it off with someone else that their
other almost fiance is watching as well
it's just it's i can't even imagine
being in a room with all my girlfriends
i have boyfriends and we're all in
serious relationships and we just go all
right let's mix it up
no it's so crazy and i've learned this
concept recently that when you're an
adult and you are told to do something
that you don't want to do something
called your inner child comes out
or your inner teenager and that's
basically when the inside of you starts
stomping your feet and saying no i'm not
gonna do that i'm gonna do what i want
so i honestly believe that if you're put
up against a wall give it an ultimatum
for marriage don't you think it would do
the exact reverse effect of what you
want well that kind of happened to tom
and katie from vanderpump rules
because they're getting divorced i am so
sad about it yeah okay so you guys know
that we are big fan of pump rules
especially sistine fans um and katie and
tom just got divorced and honestly did i
ever think they would actually last this
long no but am i really upset yeah it
you know it's one of those situations
where no one was thinking throughout the
entire show i feel for her though yeah
she's made it very clear since the
beginning of their relationship that
she's wanted marriage and babies yeah
and if you didn't want that
don't string someone along to make them
think that you're going to give that to
them
does he not want kids
he never made it clear at least on the
show see i'm only seeing it from one
point of view but on the show he never
made it clear and he always pushed it
back and waited and waited
what would you do so let's just say you
are in this ultimate
would you make give your man an
ultimatum if you were in here hell yeah
what like what do you mean
i'm sitting here five years dating i'm
gonna say
what are we doing
are we gonna either just talk about the
idea of marriage are you totally against
it and if he's like no i'm not against
him like great then let's start moving
that way and if not
i'm out like sweeta gonzalez but you
know what's okay this is also part two
of the question
so you give your man an ultimatum right
he does not want to get married soon he
doesn't want kids soon but you're really
wanting it and you're like honey
it's either you're in or you're out i'm
leaving you or you marry me right and he
says he wants to marry you
do you think
that
you forcing him
is already a sign that this isn't going
to work out in the long run because
you're making him do something he didn't
want to do initially see
yes and no
because part of me is saying
if you didn't really want this in your
heart of hearts on your own without me
telling you to do this then i don't
believe that you'd really want it right
but then the other side of me is saying
sometimes people just need a little bit
of a push
to see that there could be a possibility
of something even greater
and so that's where because sometimes
it's so difficult it's difficult because
a lot of people have the confidence and
are very sure of their choices and
aren't as indecisive and then there are
people that aren't as you know decisive
and i'm certainly that person at some
points
so i don't know it just depends ideas
marriage honestly scares me do i want it
yes
but it's i feel like we hear more about
unsuccessful marriages today than
successful ones and it's hard too
because we look at mom and dad and
they're in like a really great healthy
strong marriage
and i'm like y'all
they're just not built the same anymore
no
it's different you know what was
interesting is that this girl in tik tok
was talking about dating culture in la
and how people or even just
relationships in the states versus
everywhere else and everywhere else but
dating italy or germany or whatever it's
much more romantic and here it's just
there's no more romance i'm not saying
by the way i'm not saying that it's so
hopeless for everybody what happened to
like mr suave like picking you up on a
moped with a baguette and a bottle of
wine holding a flower in his teeth
no i don't understand i want someone to
come knocking on my door with some
flowers pick me up we do something super
cute and romantic doesn't need to be
expensive and just romance you yeah what
happened to romance i think maybe people
are afraid of romance because they think
they'll get shut down or it's corny
but i feel like we've lost that with our
generation yeah everyone loves romance i
i maybe you you're not a touchy feely
person but it's the thought
it's the appreciation it's the effort
that you put into it it's the effort i
don't know it's it's so weird i mean i
mean it's not the same for me now but it
does take though when it comes because i
was scared of marriage too i was like i
don't know
if i want to do it anytime soon i still
am like i'm one of those people i want
to figure out who i am first before even
jumping into anything like that but
it really just takes like a person or
one person to change an entire mindset
well let me ask you this because i could
easily flip the script because i know
some people are watching this and saying
well what about you guys
aren't you romantic sophia what do you
do for your boyfriend that you romance
him
um because it could go both ways
i would consider myself the romantic
yeah you know what i i am i'm very i
would say i'm romantic with
my words like i i tell the way i express
myself if i
because how i show i care about you is
showing you by giving you advice or
being there for you or being like a
mother for you
and so yes because he wants to date his
mother
yeah he wants to date his mom obviously
but that's just the way i show affection
and warmth and maybe putting an effort
into the dates i do but like it's as a
girl i think it's just more showing
affection like physically and
emotionally and that's how i do it i
just express myself when you're
uncomfortable i like let loose how do
you do it see i i like to make them fall
in love with food
because my mom taught me
the fastest way ever cooked for a guy a
lot one time no no like at least once a
week and that's a lot of work by the way
going to the market picking out a menu
which by the way here's a little life
hack i never knew what to pair with what
say if i was cooking a steak i'm like
okay well what vegetables compliment i
have no idea i would just go on a
restaurant menu that i liked and i would
literally copy an exact dish with like
if it had grilled leeks and like sauteed
carrots and mushroom on the side then
that's like that's smart yeah so that's
a little tip so my mom taught me that
the fastest way to a man's heart is
through his stomach yeah so if you feed
them they'll love you you also heard
that trend uh that if you go on a date
with a guy and it's an adrenaline rush
date that he'll associate adrenaline
with love and so he'll fall in love with
you faster
so i have to go on a roller coaster
no so there was a study that showed that
if you go on a date with someone and you
associate it with yeah with good food
and
something that builds up the intensity
with the other person and you're having
this experience with them that is
exciting and it's a rush and it's uh an
adrenaline yeah
they're gonna associate that whole
feeling of the roller coaster that did
all the work
to the girl because she was there for
the experience
that's interesting i have another tidbit
for you
i heard
that
i didn't make this up
when you go on a first date or a second
date with someone and you get all
nervous and we get what we call
butterflies in our stomach and we're
thinking oh my god i'm so excited we
automatically associate
the butterfly feeling with excitement
but
i heard
that is your body telling you
something's not right and that the
person you're with is not right for you
like what if you what if you just
changed your mindset because it could
save a lot of people a lot of time yeah
what if you just switched your mindset
saying
why am i feeling so anxious right now
that something isn't right yeah
no it could be
ted bundy it could be tim bundy yeah
that's true the butterflies you feel the
romance it's just i'm saying it's ted
yeah but you know it's interesting
because we talked about this the other
day about things we noticed early on in
relationships or dating that
we're like okay that could be a red flag
and you feel this gut thing in your
stomach and you go no no it's okay it's
okay he he answers the phone a lot
during dinner it's fine
or whatever it is i'll
you know like there's a i i remember
going out with someone and
uh he told me something that just made
my stomach drop for a second and i went
why did it feel that way and i didn't
write i didn't really like recognize it
or associate it with anything and i
thought you know i'm just overthinking
it because i i admit it i have anxiety
sometimes but i just thought and then
that was the
thing that ended what we were doing and
so listen this is where we heard this
from there's a dating expert named
matthew hussey and sophie and i would
die to have him come on the podcast one
day i've tried we will try again we were
we were young and naive back then
we're legit now we weren't legit then
and we were legit now well in our heads
do you see the color behind here you
guys we're in a legit studio look at our
head we're wearing headphones
we're a real deal
real deal anyway this guy he is wildly
popular by the way i googled him the
other day he used to date camila cabeau
how random is that whoa i know but it
must have been a very healthy
relationship because he just nails
relationships also why did they break up
if it was so healthy well that's why
we'll ask him on the show but anyway
this is what he said so if you guys ever
need advice about anything he's the guy
to go to on youtube
but he said once
red flags in the beginning of the
relationship that a lot of people see
you often ignore them because you are
just looking at this person with a
rose-colored lens and you're like you
know what like i'll make excuses for
them i like them enough like why would i
i was just funny that i said that and
that was like the yeah you're like why
would i discontinue a relationship or
something so small and minor like you
always are just kind of making excuses
looking past it because you're just so
excited about it
but those red flags that you ignored in
the beginning of the relationship are
the same reason
or
yeah the same reason that you end up
breaking up with that person at the end
of the relationship
and if you could just avoid it all
together yeah and
you know stick
with your confidence and what your gut
is telling you
like early things i would say that you
would you know what's the hardest one is
when the red flags are stuff that you
think
are positives and they end up being the
thing that completely
implodes the relationship like
love bombing for example if you guys
don't know what love bombing is it is
when you get an excessive amount of
texting gifts i'm gonna look up the
correct definition of love you
they they ask to spend time with you and
not friends and they are oh this is an
interesting definition
love bombing is a tactic some people use
to manipulate someone into jumping into
a relationship sooner and more seriously
than they'd like to it's typically done
by people who have a history of being
in abusive relationships
our narcissists or have an anxious
attachment style
well it's so the point is that they're
trying to make you get as close and
intimate with them as possible by you
sharing all these intimate details with
them and they remember them responding
with such and then adoration
and then you get attached and so a lot
of the things they do that are bad are
going to go unnoticed or
whatever and so that's a sign like you
you would think that that sounds great
who doesn't want to have attention and
love and compliments and
i want it but you know at the same time
you got to remember that a relationship
is a slow
growing one like you don't become i mean
unless you met your best friend and just
instantly clicked and like it just from
then on out but no you had to get to
know each other you have to figure out
what you like and don't like and
see if that works but that's when they
almost become like the perfect person in
the beginning but they don't share a lot
about themselves they give make you talk
the entire time because they're so
interested and oh god that you know what
we are the perfect candidate for that
because we love talking about ourselves
i know i'm like hey what else do i know
i can't shut up i like chicken soup i
don't like with my noodles you know why
because it ruins the flavor i can tell
you more about that why do people put
pasta in soup when it literally just
becomes so mushy
like why yeah
i don't mind like matzo balm no but i
don't like foods that feel like they
were already chewed for me
do you know what i mean and that's like
what a chicken noodle soup is i feel
like that's how you feel about bread
pudding
disgusting she hates bread pudding okay
i love it if you guys like bread pudding
yeah i challenge you to watch someone
actually prepare bread pudding
it's so gross they are soaking bread in
water making balls in their hands with
the dough
and sticking on a tray
that's disgusting
it's a little gross food that's man i
still eat it
i'll still have it it still tastes good
but back to what we're saying i just
think that
if you guys are feeling those
butterflies or something that feels a
little off in the beginning of the
relationship i'm just kidding
no no just just recognize it and maybe
just flag that
just put a little you know what sophia i
have to say we had such an incredible
arc in this podcast we went from giving
such toxic advice like text your ex on
their birthday as a way to slide back
into now giving you
pointers on red flags we're growing up
wow i know we really are speaking of
growing up what i've realized recently
is
now that we live apart from each other
and we are in separate relationships and
you're traveling a lot and i'm traveling
a lot we're barely in the same city at
the same time and if we are
we have our separate plans it's kind of
weird when you grew up so incredibly
close because
you scarlett and i are just like thick
as thieves growing up we did everything
together to now
as you're getting older
you start to do very few things together
only things that are required for an
entire family to be there i know i mean
it's like you and i have a different
kind of i think situated lately it's
been a little bit chaotic i've been
we've been just gone every other weekend
not with each other but
yeah i don't know that's like one of the
sad things about growing up is we used
to share a room all three of us together
and now we're just
yeah we you guys we used to share a room
this is a funny story so sophia and i
had twin beds next to each other and
then scarlett was about
four years old maybe she felt really
left out so she got my mom bought her an
air mattress blew it up put it in front
of our two beds so she slept on an air
mattress for three or four years
and then on top of that we had three
pomeranians in a cage in the bedroom so
we had three pomeranians and three girls
for about
five or six years for a long time
bedroom i know it's a different
transition because we're all so close
but
i in this time of my i feel like it's
really exciting to do this stuff it's
hard because i think i have had to and i
feel like you've had to also figure out
who you are more as
your own person and like what you aspire
and what you dream of and who you want
to date and who you want to be with and
it's just yeah it's it's weird because
like i feel like i'm we're like glued at
the hip for a lot of things and we
always say we're like dependent on each
other and then now not being together
we're like okay now we have to
yeah take a step back i'm only going to
see you on holidays but you've been in
palm beach alone a lot
let me tell you
i
finally get it
i'm sick of middle child syndrome
something that i've dealt with my whole
life
neglected ignored
i'm not the problematic child i'm the
easiest child mom says
so i think i'm the favorite right now
i'm
400 110
110
i think i'm the easiest right now
you're the easiest right yeah
are you joking
sophia
sistine this entire month you think i
haven't been the easiest child
exactly give me the credit usually i i
always admit when it's like me off i win
today
i don't even remember what i was saying
you said that you don't like middle
child syndrome because now you get a lot
of attention
being alone in palm beach yes i like
being alone i don't like when you and
scarlet are around because i get so much
love from mom and dad and it's amazing
so i just need to figure out a way to
secretly assassinate the both of you
or we just never come to florida and you
just stay here with mom and dad forever
i could do that too hmm 40 years old
live with mom and dad sounds like the
perfect life you sound jealous
i am a okay not doing that okay should
we do unsolicited advice yeah let's go
into it do you want to read it
yes
this person is from humbled hud 24.
i absolutely love the podcast channel
keep up the wonderful work that you both
have been doing thank you my one
question to you both is how do you
handle your mental health
can we start sure
i love this topic
because i think that it's something that
is so
so so stigmatized and every single
person in the world deals with it in
their own way whether in it's extreme or
it's very subtle and
for me
when because i look cesina are totally
different people the way she approaches
it is different from how i approach it
but as i've always said on the show i'm
very vocal about how i feel and
when i'm feeling off or i'm feeling
scared i'm one of those people that i
don't let myself
sit and be
sad or anxious long enough for me to
really feel horrible and so i'm always
expressing myself and going i need help
or i need to talk to someone and
one thing i've learned because just dive
into it a little bit more
is that when you're feeling
anxious or sad or whatever your
mental health
thing is
do not feel like you should push away
from the people that love you that want
to help you and you should lean in
because i think that when you're in a
mindset that is
scary and chaotic and you have
absolutely no control and you feel like
you're the only one dealing with it you
start to
isolate yourself and
think that the best way to be is to be
completely alone and sometimes that's
actually the worst thing to do because
now you're sitting with yourself and
you're even sadder and your mind is
racing and how do you handle it yeah
that's what i'm saying is for me being
open and talking to my loved ones and
not pushing the way and leaning into
them has always been a really big help
for me and if you don't have that in
your life
maybe you find that one friend or you go
online and you find that person that
specialist that will do that for you
because there's a lot of groups there's
a lot
of resources out there that you can do
and you can look up and
i mean and they will open
their arms completely for you so that's
how i handle it how do you
but you also journal
no yeah but i don't that's not for
my anxiety or my mental health i just do
it because i enjoy it to think about
memories and i just write down my
emotions but but when i'm having a my
mental health thing i talk i talk to my
family i talk to my talk to you i talk
to dad i talk to
if i need a therapist a therapist but
i'm just saying what
i do for that is leaning into people
yeah i
pretty much have the same answer
mental health is something
new that i've started to understand a
little bit better because i always
thought that
i didn't struggle with mental health
because i would hear
stories and see what i thought mental
health would look like i'm like well i
don't fit into that mold of it and that
was a very ignorant way to think i just
didn't understand it and i was just
naive to it
and now that
i've sort of taken a step back and
realized that hold on i am struggling
with something once i admitted to myself
that i'm struggling the best way for me
to release it is confiding in those that
i love the old me would just bottle it
inside and thought okay if i didn't
address it the problem didn't exist but
it just made everything so much worse
and sometimes my favorite way to
approach it is
even if
i don't want a response because it is
really good to talk to loved ones but
that also comes with feedback and
opinions on what they think is best for
you and sometimes you really know what's
best for you but it just helps to get
that weight off your shoulders and just
let it out
so i like to just talk and be like i
don't want a response just let me cry
scream i'm going to say ridiculous
things that you're probably not going to
agree with but not having a response or
judgment back
i think is really great just being a
sounding board just a sounding board
yes and i think if you know someone that
is struggling with something and you
don't really know what to do
be that sounding board and say you will
be that sounding board i think sometimes
when you
people have a really hard time thinking
they're going to be judged and i think
that's the reason why people don't open
up and i think that's like why sometimes
you didn't open up and i i think i
now understanding it more
i want to give everyone on this planet
like more of a break
if someone's having a bad day or they're
snapping at you and you're taking it
personally like why are you getting mad
at me what did i do to you
probably nothing but it's important to
understand that every single person is
going through something
and that's not a way that i used to
think and everyone's struggling whether
you can see it on the outside or not
whether someone is more vulnerable and
open to talking about it or someone
literally will act like nothing's wrong
everyone has [ __ ] yeah so just be kind
yeah and i that just be kind but also if
you are the person that's struggling
don't also
think that that's an excuse to be rude
to people as as well i think like that
it can go both ways i you know i just
think
be open be honest and you know lean in
and know that there are people out there
for you that want to help and want to
talk to you about it because it's an
ongoing thing it's never going to
fully disperse forever and ever and ever
i mean just like everything in life but
i just think that the earlier you
open up and the faster that you want to
get it fixed or at least managed is
going to be the best thing for you and
you want to be happy and healthy i agree
and if you want your unsolicited advice
answered make sure you go to the apple
podcast page go to the unlocks podcast
go to ratings and review
write your question in the ratings and
review section five stars
that is the only way we are going to
answer it and yes please give us five
stars or sex if that's even possible so
i did something kind of random yesterday
and i just put a poll up on instagram
and i cause i really like hearing from
you guys and answering your questions
directly because
i just feel closer and i just feel like
we can grow as an unwaxer community so i
put a poll up and i just said questions
for the girls and you guys actually came
up with some really solid questions can
i also say something that just happened
recently is someone came up to me and
said that them and the roommates
listened to our podcast it was like a
group of girls what's up girls i know
and you know what's it's so interesting
i feel like you feel the same way
i still don't think anyone is listening
to this show i'm sorry i know you
probably are like sophia come on sistine
you guys are whack we i genuinely think
we have 10 listeners
and i feel like nine of them are men
that are in their 80s like
the other ones are mom
the last one is mom mom's the only girl
scout it's not listening but like it's
just it's like it is crazy because
sometimes we'll just yeah people come up
off the street or we'll say my friend or
my sister and my roommate
they listen oh my god it's so bad
because we're always like
what what why that's amazing like thank
you because that's our goal i mean
especially when it's young girls or
girls that are our age it makes my day
so much and then i think about
everything i've said on the show i'm
like oh my god i've given horrible
advice i think horrible i hope it's just
for entertainment purposes for y'all but
sometimes like today we gave good ones
but yeah we really really appreciate
everybody listening and we love when you
girls come up and guys
if you're not creepy um come up and you
say let you listen to it it makes us
really happy and also we love reading
your dm's we answer pretty much all of
them so yeah yeah actually the guy that
was making my smoothie the other day
said he listens to the show i was like
dude thank you awesome great smoothie my
waiter gave me a free dessert because he
says he likes the podcast come on
yeah oh god i loved it
give us free stuff i'll see you all day
bye if you're like
i don't know like work at sephora and
you just want to give me a ton of stuff
like that's fine yeah
yeah yeah or just like free cake from
cheesecake factory or just an envelope
full of cash we'll take it we'll take it
anything i take gift cards too so let's
start with these questions please the
first one is i think actually i wrote
this one down for you because you've
been going to new york quite a bit this
person asked what's the coolest must-see
place in manhattan i wasn't really in
manhattan that much too okay well let's
say new york coolest must-play sea in
new york that you've experienced okay
you know what i did recently for the
first time that was really interesting
we both hadn't done it was go to the 911
museum
the memorial yeah yeah i did that last
time i was there and it was
wow and you know what it
unbelievably sad of course and
i think for me going and seeing that
just kind of reminded me
it's
i don't know how lucky you are and how
fragile life is and it's just i
i love that they put so much work and
love and memory into this
memorial place it's beautiful yeah it's
beautiful and it's tragic but it is like
it really just shifts your mindset for a
bed and i definitely recommend going
okay good yeah what do you do if you're
in an awkward situation and don't know
how to act or respond okay you do two
things it's really simple
first you go into the robot and then you
transition by walking out of the room
doing the moonwalk and that's how you
leave an awkward situation if you're
asking me personally i keep talking
until it gets even more awkward and then
i realize i don't know what i'm saying
and then i usually say i'm sorry i don't
know what i'm saying oh well here's a
real answer from me when i'm in an
awkward situation i don't really know
what to do 99 of the time i will go to
the nearest bathroom sit in the largest
stall facetime sophia for about 20
minutes which kills 20 minutes of my
night
that is true
but then people also think that you're
taking a number two
it's better than instead of having a
horrible conversation rather than
thinking i'm pooping okay that's fine so
when did you realize you were an adult
i know the answer to this when i started
paying taxes
yeah i never thought i would actually
have to as a child and now that i do it
sucks
i also think when someone ids me like i
usually never get id'd oh it's a good
one yeah and now i mean like when even
when i'm 25 like i usually don't get i i
look pretty young but that when i i've
been getting it recently and now i'm
thinking or
when you buy a house plant for yourself
that's pretty adult
yeah that's pretty adult when you're
moving in by yourself any advice for
people putting too much pressure on
themselves i just had this talk the
other day is it gonna
make you feel better or put the pressure
away
no
right
so
just try to snap yourself out of it we
all do it everyone's human but just
remind yourself you're doing everything
you can and if you don't feel like
you're doing everything you can the only
way to change that
is by putting in some action and also
let me just say this because i was i had
this um i've always struggled with
putting pressure on myself a lot and
that's probably where a lot of my
anxiety comes from and i was having a
talk the other day and
i was just thinking about first of all
i'm 25 but also whatever age you are
what is anybody else doing
right now what is your friend doing
what is your other friend doing what is
your sister doing what is your brother
doing what's your third friend yeah
what's your third friend doing if you
have a third friend what does my dog do
but really think about what those people
are doing
and are they doing
ten thousand times don't compare
yourself to the kylie jenners or
the whitney herds or the elon musk it's
just point zero zero zero one percent
you know if you're comparing yourself to
people that are just an unrealistic
standard to compare yourself to i mean
you're just setting yourself up to fail
yeah and i understand that it's easy to
compare yourself to people on tick tock
and all that stuff but a lot of those
content creators that is their job they
are constantly making that stuff so it
seems like their life is totally perfect
and maybe they have a good balance but
do not
compare yourself because their life is
their life your life is your life you
know whenever you put pressure on
something whether it's a boo-boo
or
you know a relationship
what does pressure feel like it's
painful it doesn't feel good it's
uncomfortable so don't put pressure on
your heart
okay
that was
so deep uh who instigates most of the
fights between you guys
i'd say it's 50 each of us yeah i feel
like it just depends yeah it depends on
the morning depends who got a better cup
of coffee
and then it goes from there i'm such
it's kind of funny he saw me uh making
my car i'm like very specific with my
coffee now so we have coffees do you
guys froth your coffees your creamers
and stuff no i love how it's foaming on
top
and i hate foam on my coffee
because first of all you have to swallow
like four gulps of thumb but it tastes
great before you can even get to the
coffee and you're like just drinking
like foamy milk it's so great my coffee
tastes like a slight like a milkshake a
little bit and it's perfect it's such a
nice way to wake up what are your
favorite makeup products
okay i feel like the best way to answer
this question
is
with another question
if you were on a deserted island and you
could bring three makeup products what
would they be
easily
i'd bring a cream blush and the one i
would bring right now because i changed
my favorite makeup products 24 7. so
this is just as of now i think for both
of us
i would bring the rare beauty happy
liquid blush because that is so
pigmented and it lasts forever two
concealer specifically anastasia beverly
hills concealer that [ __ ] is thick and
it is good because i have dark circles
and a lot of little pimples and i need
to get rid of them and then three
i would say
my
brow gel actually just kidding just
kidding i would bring a lip mask
i'm so specific with hydrating my lips
and i think i would bring one of those i
don't have like a specific one but one
that is a pigmented lip oil or lip gloss
okay yeah i would agree with the brow i
would bring a tinted brow gel
i love a fluffy brow
two
i would bring which i probably put on
every single day with no makeup is the
charlotte tilbury
uh cream blush
like little stick wand oh it's like a
highlighter and pink ass pink gasm great
name
and then three i would probably bring
like a very dark brown maybe the nars
stripped down lip liner
uh i love a giant you're on a deserted
island and you bring yeah i'm gonna have
some dsls on that yeah i was like some
thick lips because you know what like if
you don't like sometimes i will this
sounds insane but i love just putting a
little bit of something on before i
leave the door and if i don't feel like
doing a full beat with foundation and
and blush and bronzer and all that crap
if i just do my brows a little bit of
blush
and a sick lip liner it literally looks
like you're wearing a full face yeah it
does it does pulls it together okay
someone asked
dating co-workers
that's gonna be a no from me dog
i have never experienced that so i don't
know from all of the um rom-coms i've
watched it end up turning out good but
the middle part's not that great tell me
this riddle me this why on every rom-com
when the co-workers date they have the
most steamy sexual hot
love scenes because you've ever seen oh
wow and it's like
why
because you work in the same office
building you guys are both
so extra like extremely sexually
compatible
and kinky
it's just it's it's it's so wrong it's
right
okay i just say no unless it's the love
of your life it's gonna you have to make
messy you do you use the questions in
the beginning that i asked do they
support you do they love you and do that
okay on the first date
did you ever have a guy respond with my
girlfriend instead of my ex is this a
red flag
1 trillion
have you ever had that no
thank god
i have that is a huge red flag i'm sorry
i mean unless they broke up with them a
day ago
yeah i mean i've never i've never even
said that i've ever said oh yeah my my
boyfriend talking to a guy i've had i've
had a guy say my girlfriend then quickly
correct himself into
my ex and i was like is she your ex
jesus when did you guys break up you
obviously care about her if you're
calling her your girlfriend
red flag
so many red flags okay
what is your go-to comfort movie slash
self-care routine after you've had a
really bad day
yes this question
yes go ahead
all right
number one i am putting on
you know how in every closet you just
have like really ugly sweatpants that
are so baggy and comfortable but
probably have old stains on them and you
can't wear them in public
those comfort sweatpants sweatshirt duo
then i'm putting on my giant fuzzy socks
then i'm probably going to put on
some really bad reality tv right now i'm
on that summer house kick but actually
it's great tv to be honest all right
then i'm going to get some snacks i'm
loving pop chips right now
i'm loving what else do we like
we love rice cakes the cinnamon ones
from cinnamon rice cakes yeah
ones those are good uh and i will just
make a little
arrangement of of chips and crap and
candy in front of me
and i will just sit on my couch with a
giant weighted blanket probably a
heating pad and hibernate
that's what i'm doing you know i did um
a couple days actually a couple months
ago this was like my favorite night ever
i put on the ugly sweatpants pull over
put on a headband did a facial mask a
brightening one yeah i love masks got my
favorite food i got whatever it was and
then i put on the princess bride
and it was so romantic and fun or you
watch the holiday if it's the holidays
see no i would not want to watch for
romantic i love romantic and i also
don't want to like make myself feel
better by doing facials and stuff
because if i'm in a bad mood well i'm
avoiding all mirrors well that's
different that's if you're in a bag well
she said if you have a bad day yeah you
make yourself feel better by making
yourself look better drink a lot of wine
all right get drunk next question sofia
do you guys think you'll go on a podcast
story yes we hope so we have always
talked about this we would love to go
live and travel around and see you guys
in person obviously that is uh
a goal but it and then we haven't
planned anything well let me ask you
guys this
would you show up yeah that's honestly
my fear is back to what i said that i
don't feel like anyone is listening
would like would those ten people come
sophie and i've been wanting to do a
live show or go on tour
so badly but
how horrible would it be if no one
bought a ticket that's what i'm saying
it's like i so i want to do this and i
feel like maybe we wait till our podcast
grows a little bit more i don't know
okay what is your advice from moving on
from a toxic friendship
friendships are hard because sometimes
they're harder than a breakup if they
were a really good friend to you
or you guys were very close
the only way to move on is just take it
day by day there's no specific tool or
something you can do
i would
i don't know
handle it the same way as breaking up
with
your significant other i guess moving on
from a toxic friendship
um well you recognize it's toxic in the
first place step so that's pretty good
two
you just do yeah there's nothing i'm
sorry that's it like
just like everything takes time and
guess what now i just got rid of someone
that was and now you're gonna get
someone that's good and maybe you know
you could take this opportunity at to
reach out to a friend that you normally
don't but they've always been very sweet
to you and you could see what would come
out of that friendship and guess what
the re you know how you move on you
become friends with us and you listen to
the show
we're your built-in friend yeah we are
your friends i love this next question
celebrity crush celebrity crush
can i guess yours and you can guess mine
okay
okay your celebrity crush
you have like five you have so many too
i have like two main ones
i think i even know either one
i've said them so many times give me a
hint
okay one i liked him when he was younger
peter pan no
oh celebrity crush that's he's a cartoon
no it's a little boy
ew
when you were younger you said this is a
celebrity crush it's not my childhood
crush that's different
oh okay yours is killig murphy and it's
jason momoa and
shelby yeah and it's
um uh what's his name from crazy rich
asians
henry goulding it's henry goulding jason
momoa and gilligan murphy
uh okay
yours
is
rob lowe and tom hardy i've said this to
you so many times
why do you like rob lowe i said the
young version well that doesn't count i
love you that's also all comfortable
elmo's fire
you gotta take them as they are today
and i would tell them all three of them
tom hardy yeah he is by the way actually
actually comfort movie this means war
chris pine tom hardy and reese
witherspoon there's tell me right now
that's not the hottest trio ever
and they're so hot don't worry again
oh my god venom don't even she is so
spicy i know
no venom i yeah y'all are probably
laughing at me i love it yeah venom
yo no hold up even when he is a
disgusting
like
slime monster i'm still like
what you're getting cute
i would totally go out with you because
because you remember in the first movie
when
like venom the monster kissed
tom hardy's ex yeah so i was like
okay all right
right but wait the fact that i watched
venom two and then watched phantom one
because i was like you know i also see
this i bought it on my computer i'm
gonna watch it it's so i told her i was
like hey you gotta watch the show this
movie venom and she goes okay whatever
and i was like i don't know if she's
gonna like it she doesn't love like
sci-fi [ __ ] she came out she was like
that was the best movie literally the
best okay we're like huge venom
everyone feel like that is the cheesiest
one we are going to comic con and
dressing as venom i love venom
i love tom hardy
no no like i literally have a crush on
the monster i have a crush on the slime
monster you can take that out i'll take
tommy i'll take either version of tom i
don't care i'm not picky oh my god i am
obsessed oh my god you know i like tom
too because like he kind of has like a
little like snaggletooth
oh god
like he's like a backyard boy you know
you should chop an ex oh my god would
that be some and uh peaky binders
when your two crushes
collide
in one scene this was the best show ever
i think i'm killing it murphy tom hardy
i think i
combusted
if he did a combat sound
i got chills okay we gotta stop we're so
this is the longest answer to anything
i'm getting hot and bothered
move on next question
one skincare product you can't live
without sunscreen
[Music]
moisturizer oh no i'm still thinking
about that
no i can't talk about that does he wear
sunblock
i don't know
he doesn't need it he doesn't need he
doesn't burn he's too hot oh my god i
think i like him more than deadpool
because i love they're kind of similar
with their they're like deadpool is like
10 notches down thank you
deadpool venom like they both have the
same vibe of being funny
but just tom hardy is funny without
being funny yeah oh my god whereas
deadpool's like
always making jokes
i know
why does ryan reynolds play the same
character in every movie movie free guy
he was basically the same character
kinda
yeah he was in that one jason state them
he was the same character
what's another one there's deadpool
and then there's he's always like the
like quirky
funny
cute guy just friends or yeah just
friends just friends
but tom hardy doesn't do that
[Music]
tom hardy is a shape-shifter every time
he's on the screen you don't even know
who he is because he's so enveloped in
the character so that you can't even
tell so is jason mama
not really he plays aquaman
but he looks the same in everything i
think well because he because he how
where do you how do you cast him you
can't cast him as like the sweet old man
he's a targaryen oh you know what i also
just watched uh speaking of sci-fi i
watched in the plane was that new
spider-man movie
and by the way i've never i love how you
just said that new spider-man movie as
if it didn't do over a billion dollars
well the thing is is that i i don't
watch all the spider-man like in the
spidey universe like what did you think
tom holland is super cute he's a great
actor
tom holland that's another tom that's
very cute i'll leave you guys with this
many moons ago when i just joined raya
and i was 18. gosh
tom holland
of course this is before all of his
girlfriends and his ex-girlfriends was
on raya
and what did i do
i don't think my my finger almost went
through the phone screen i hit yes so
hard
i did not get a yes back
obviously why would tom holland yeah why
would tom long
but just tom hardy
here's the thing
probably not either
i just want an intervention for the toms
should we just put all toms in a room
what's another time tom schwartz
what a combo okay this uh ending was
actually hilarious but also just
whatever but we love you guys so much
thank you so much for tuning in to
another episode of
okay we're so annoying we love you guys
we'll see you next tuesday adios
[Music]
you